okay so I have to confess something when
I first saw the iPhone six-plus I
thought it was kind of bonkers I mean I
get it people seem to really want larger
phones these days and Apple doesn't want
to leave any money on the table but have
you seen this thing I mean look this is
the 6 plus here's the iPhone 6 Batman
little boy that size is due to a display
that is larger than anything that's ever
appeared in an iPhone before but such a
honkin big screen makes for well kind of
an unwieldy phone I mean even with
Apple's clever reach ability screen
shrinking feature the iPhone 6 plus can
be kind of hard to handle if you don't
have giant NBA sized hands pocket
ability is another issue at 71
millimeters thick the iPhone 6 plus is
thin enough to fit into your pocket kind
of if you're into that sort of thing but
don't try sitting on and unless you like
the feeling of a 2x4 strapped to your
behind
so there's your newsflash larger things
are more cumbersome than smaller things
so those were my first impressions and I
do stand by them but there is I
discovered a different way to think
about the iPhone 6 plus and that started
happening when I used it like I used my
regular iPhone watching videos replying
to emails reading things off the web
man that bigger screen is nice with some
apps the iPhone 6 plus has different and
useful viewing modes when you turn it on
its side emails and messages take on a
more efficient layout and expanded
keyboard has dedicated keys for
copy/paste
and cursor movement videos are more fun
to watch and I certainly appreciated
reading on a large bright screen such as
this a larger size also means a larger
battery the iPhone 6 plus can do 12
hours of LTE browsing or 16 days of
standby time here's another thing about
the iPhone 6 plus it has the best camera
Apple has ever made that means it can
focus fast
a DSLR and shoot super slow-mo video but
it's also the first iPhone with optical
image stabilization that means that the
lens actually moves around within the
device to counter any shake that you
might create while holding it the result
is better low-light performance and
smoother video so what's the verdict
here it's tricky in some ways the issues
are more philosophical than
technological if we think of the iPhone
six-plus as a phone then it does seem
sort of large and clunky the standard
iPhone 6 does many of the same things in
a much smaller more convenient package
but maybe phone is the wrong word to
describe this iPhone what we actually
have here is a nearly pocketable tablet
with a killer camera a great display and
guess what it will even make some phone
calls